the Jersey Shore gang is together again
and they're taking a family vacation and
for mom of two Nicole aka Snooki
it looks like habits are a little bit
hard to break so I got into a little
trouble just come around when it comes
to mom raging oh my god
[Music]
all of us roomies we're such a hot mess
like we have families where you know
more mature but when we get together
we're just generates from this to this
almost 10 years later the seven
roommates have relocated to Miami for
MTV's new season of Jersey Shore Emily
vacation are you guys still obsessed
with Gym tan laundry oh yes that is the
fun way life JWoww and Snooki each have
a son and a daughter now but they're not
ready to talk to them about their Jersey
Shore Pass a woman came up to me she
goes hey Snooki and my son looks at me
and he goes mommy who is Snooki and I'm
like what's happening I need you to
explain to him what a Snooki is and I
don't even know what to say
dude I'm screwed feel like we're classy
now the women became more chic
muhuali looks exactly the same the
hairstyle is is here and here to stay
I don't know I just feel like if God
bless you with his hairline why change
it but all the roommates agree the
biggest transformation has been Mike the
situation can't wait to see my friends I
do this I actually have a little bit
over two years clean and sober now and
I'm so proud to sit in this chair today
hold my head high and let everyone you
know see that person if Mike can make it
through Jersey Shore reunion he can make
it through life I love that in Big Ups
to him congratulations Mike and for
those of you Jersey Shore superfans who
are wondering where is Sam Sarika well
she opted out of the reunion series the
cast told me Sam he's in a good place in
her life she's in a pretty serious
relationship she did want to do it
they're cool with it they respect her
[Music]